c'est dans son pôle de formation et
d'expérimentations sur l'énergie
installé aux mureaux kennedy ça fait le
bilan de ses investissements
raccordement pour les nouveaux clients
ou encore entretien des treize mille
kilomètres de réseau 70 millions d'euros
sont investis chaque année dans les
yvelines
un chiffre qui ne cesse d'augmenter la
région ile de france est très dynamique
parce que vous avez des grands projets
comme le grand paris comme les jeux
olympiques comme la construction
immobilière autour des gares qui sortent
de terre
et puis tout simplement le dynamisme
économique de la région ile de france
qui se retrouve évidemment dans les
yvelines
sollicité par le comité des jeux
olympiques est née 10 sera notamment en
charge du raccordement électrique sur
les sites heavy noah accueillant des
épreuves des jo 2000 24 autres projets
dans les années à venir a développé la
transition énergétique sur notre
territoire
préparer les nouveaux modes de
consommation dans les logements pour
être plus économe être capable de
développer du photovoltaïque sur
l'ensemble des toitures des yvelines
pour qu'enfin les yvelines et
l'ile-de-france d'une manière générale
deviennent plus producteur et -
importateurs d'énergie puisque
aujourd'hui l'île de france importe
beaucoup d'énergie de l'extérieur est
née 10 poursuit également le déploiement
des compteurs linky en 2021 l'ensemble
des yvelines devraient en être équipés